PSA Peugeot Citroën très présent dans le
département des Yvelines notamment pour
la fabrication de la 208 Alexandre co
bonsoir vous êtes chef de produits de de
la 208 on est juste devant les modèles
xy et la modèle GTI également qui sont
deux modèles qui sont fabriqués à poissi
exclusivement à poiss qu'est-ce qui
distingue ces deux modèles des autres
donc ces deux modèles sont nos deux
versions distinctives c'està-dire des
des des voitures qui euh sont une
réponse au marché des voitures premium
donc c'est notre proposition 208 XY 208
GTI de version haut de gamme distinctive
qui se reconnaissent parmi toutes les
208 par de nombreux éléments de style un
tipage très fort ce qu'on appelle une
posture de la voiture donc une voiture
qui se reconnaît dès qu'elle roule euh
et un traité très technologique très
stylé très raffiné donc on est dans du
haut de gamme là sur ces véhicules là
sur ces véhicules on est dans du haut de
gamme parmi une gamme qui est large bien
sûr 208 mais c'est vraiment notre
proposition haut de gamme qui qui qui
qui contient tout le raffinement que les
clients du premium attend accessible à
partir de quel prix ceci dit on va pas
parler du prix disponible quand
également peut les prix Les prix de la
XY ne sont pas encore
communiqué et les prix de la GTI ont été
fixés en France à partir de 24500 € les
voitures seront disponibles au printemps
2013 probablement après le Salon de
Genève si je simplifie un petit peu il y
a un véhicule pour les femmes un
véhicule pour les hommes XY femmes GTI
plus sportif pour les hommes non parce
que parce que la clientèle des voitures
distinctives et pas est pas forcément
que des femmes ou que des hommes il y a
c'est des gens qui ont d'horizon très
très divers on a une GTI qui
effectivement correspond au code et au
mythes de la GTI de la GTI Peugeot en
particulier et on a une XY qui est une
expression vraiment d'une montée en
gamme et qui peut tant convenir aux
hommes qu'aux femmes euh cette voiture
là présenté avec sa teinte purple night
donc un très joli violet très très
exclusif mais il y aura d'autres teintes
disponibles qui peut-être vous feront
moins penser à une voiture pour les pour
les femmes là on le voit bien sur sur le
Salon de l'Auto sur la présentation de
ce véhicule de ces de 208 et de la 208
en général c'est un véhicule qui occupe
une grande place sur le stand de Peugeot
Peugeot met tous ses efforts sur ce
véhicule là Peugeot ne met pas tous ses
efforts mais c'est effectivement une
voiture très importante puisque c'est
une voiture qui pour qui pourrait
représenter jusqu'à 40 % de nos ventes
mondiales donc c'est effectivement une
voiture extrêmement importante c'est
aussi une voiture qui cont pardon
continue l'histoire de la série 2 de
Peugeot qui qui est une histoire
ininterrompue les gens ont tous en tête
205 206 207 on a une 208 qui est une
vraie régénération cette histoire mais
qui qui est importante parce que parce
que c'est la série mythique de Peugeot
et Peugeot a envie justement de de
retrouver ses clients qui étaient
habitués à ces véhicules là et de se
relancer on a beaucoup parlé de Peugeot
forcément ces derniers temps pour des
difficultés économique a des
licenciements mais il faut aussi faire
rêver et puis refédérer les gens et les
faire revenir vers la marque il les
faire revenir oui oui mais la 207 a été
un succès la 208 fonctionne très bien on
a pris déjà plus de 120000 commandes
depuis le lancement donc il y a pas de
il y a pas de problème de d'absence de
clientèle simplement il y a des marchés
qui sont difficiles marchés européens
qui sont très difficiles cette année on
les attend difficiles aussi l'année
prochaine mais la 208 a tous les atouts
de modernité de capacité de technologie
pour pour relever ce défi et prendre le
leadership du segment en Europe merci
Alexandre Cazo pour ces précisions on
continue à faire un tour d'horizon on va
rester un petit peu sur le stand de
Peugeot